hottest movie trended on Twitter
yesterday based on a real story in
November 1985 a hunter discovered a dead
175 pound black bear nearby was a duffel
bag that had originally contained
roughly 75 pounds the unfortunate animal
had apparently gotten into the an
overdosed later dubbed Pablo Esco bear
or simply and now they're making a movie
about it oh I hope Pixar is all over
this by the way that's 85 before
fentanyl that bear would have been dead
in two seconds but at least he probably
had a good run around the forest with
that but yeah that's the thing you've
got to scrape the barrel if you're not
going to do more redones of top gun that
has taken that's what's happening next I
love it